-The one-year anniversary of
President Trump's inauguration
was marked this weekend
by nationwide protests
and a government shutdown
that ended today
despite Trump doing as little
as possible it resolve it.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's been a year since
Trump's inauguration
and the historic
women's marches that followed.
And on Saturday, we saw yet
again that the women's march
wasn't merely
a one-time phenomenon,
but a sustained movement
unlike anything the country's
seen in decades.
-Women across the country were
on the march today.
Thousands took to the streets
from coast to coast.
They rallied for a variety
of causes with a focus
on having their voices heard
in November's midterm elections.
-Taking to the streets in over
300 rallies in all 50 states.
-But it just wasn't in the U.S.
where women marched.
This was the scene in
Nova Scotia, where half the town
of Sandy Cove also participated
in the women's march.
-Wow.
Half the town was protesting.
That, I have to say...
[ Applause ]
That's got to be super awkward
for people who weren't there.
[ Laughter ]
"Dale, I didn't see you
at the women's march."
"Oh, yeah,
was it a good turnout?"
"Half, Dale! It was half."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, one of the best parts
of any protests are the signs,
and this year was especially
refreshing
to see children participating,
like this sign
that said "Vote for women!"
This sign that said
"boys are equal to girls
and girls are equal to boys,"
and then there was
this little girl
who clearly got
to write her own sign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Although...
[ Applause ]
To be fair, it's possible
she spent more time on that
than the Trump administration
did on the original travel ban.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
[ Imitating Trump ]
"Don't forget.
"Don't forget
the purple circles.
The purple circles make it
legally airtight."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Trump, who was cooped
up in the White House
all weekend watching coverage
of the protests,
couldn't help but weigh in,
tweeting...
Dude, you know that's not why
they were marching.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's the kind of guy, who if
he came home to find his wife
dumped all his clothes on
the sidewalk, would say to her,
"I get it.
You want to see me naked."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I pick up on stuff.
I pick up on stuff."
[ Applause ]
So the one-year anniversary
of Trump's inauguration
saw a second straight year of
sustained nationwide protests
but, of course, it wasn't just
the protests
that marred Trump's celebration.
-The government is shut down
for the first time
in more than four years.
"The Art of the Deal" President
could not reach that deal
with Democrats
and a few Republicans,
and just a few hours ago, they
marked the one-year anniversary
of his presidency
by rejecting a budget bill.
-This is the first time
in modern history,
the first time
in modern U.S. history,
that a party that's controlled
the House, the Senate,
and the White House,
has had a government shutdown
on their watch.
-You got to hand it to Trump,
he finally did something no
other President has ever done.
[ Imitating Trump ] "Bush
couldn't do it, Obama couldn't.
We made history.
We made history."
Now Trump has, of course, tried
to claim it's actually Democrats
who will suffer politically
from the shutdown,
tweeting over the weekend...
But there's at least one
immutable law of physics
that still applies
in Washington.
For each Trump quote, there's an
equal and opposite Trump quote.
And the question of who's to
blame for government shutdowns
is no exception because when
Obama was President,
Trump was very clear about
who was to blame.
-Who's going to bear the brunt
of the responsibility
if, indeed, there is a shutdown
of our government?
-Well, if you say,
"who gets fired?" it always has
to be the top. I mean,
problems start from the top,
and have to get solved
from the top,
and the President's the leader.
In 25 years, in 50 years,
in a hundred years from now,
when the government is,
you know, they talk
about the government shutdown,
they're going to be talking
about the President
of the United States.
Who was the President
at that time?
If there is a shutdown,
I think it would be
a tremendously negative mark
on the President
of the United States.
I hear the Democrats are going
to be blamed
and the Republicans
are going to be blamed.
I actually think the President
would be blamed.
-There's literally, literally...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...not one situation where there
isn't an old Trump quote
that completely contradicts
his current position.
I wouldn't be surprised if
there's an old Trump tweet
out there that says,
"Only a loser
would wear a baseball cap
with a suit."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Trump was asked
point-blank in 2011 how he would
handle a potential shutdown
differently
from then-President Obama.
And in retrospect, let's say
he was a little overconfident.
-I'm a deal man. I made hundreds
and hundreds of deals
and transactions.
He never did deals before.
How can you expect a man
that's not a deal man
that never did a deal
other than, frankly,
becoming President
of the United States,
he never did a deal --
how is he going to corral all
these people?
-So how would you do it now?
Now you're in the Oval Office
right now, it's Wednesday --
-I would get everybody together
and we'd have a budget.
-They've all gotten together.
-Well, that's because they
don't have the right leader.
You don't have the right leader.
This is the President
of the United States
has to get this done,
but it's pretty sad
because the whole world
is looking at us
and laughing at us.
[ Laughter ]
-It's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I agree with everything
he just said.
Of course, in reality,
Republicans control
all three branches of government
and on top of that,
we have a President
who repeatedly sold himself
on the campaign trail
as an ultimate dealmaker.
-We need a President that's
going to be able to make deals,
great deals.
I want to make great deals.
That's what it is.
For the people.
I do hundreds of deals.
The deals come out of my ears.
If you can't make a good deal
with a politician,
then there's
something wrong you.
You're certainly not very good.
You can't leave the White House,
go to Hawaii and play golf
for three weeks
and be a real dealmaker.
It doesn't work that way.
-That's right. You can't go
to Hawaii to play golf
and be a dealmaker.
You have to go to Florida.
And you can't do it
for three weeks.
You have to do it
for an entire year.
And yet even as the government
shutdown ended,
the self-proclaimed deal man
was M.I.A.,
completely absent
from the negotiations
and leaving everyone confused
about where he stood.
In fact, in order to counter
that growing impression
that Trump was sitting around
doing nothing,
the White House released
a series of official photos
of what they called
President Donald J. Trump
working in the White House
during the Democrat shutdown,
including this photo of Trump
walking around,
this photo of Trump talking
to people,
and this photo of Trump
supposedly on the phone.
Look at him. [ Imitating Trump ]
"Hello, police, come quick.
Somebody stole
all the work off my desk."
[ Laughter ]
You know, you don't really look
like you're working
when you're staring directly
at the camera.
You look like you just got
busted having phone sex.
[ Imitating Trump ] "I got to...
call you back."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The main reason the government
was in this mess
in the first place
was that Trump doesn't know
what he believes other
than the fact that he spent
the entire campaign promising
to build a wall,
and now his party's scrambling
to find a way to follow through
on that promise even though
they know it's absurd.
Even Trump's Chief of Staff,
John Kelly,
reportedly told lawmakers
Trump's promises on the wall
were uninformed and is now
saying the so-called wall
doesn't even have to be
an actual physical barrier.
-Did he really say the President
was uninformed on the wall?
-Yes. Well, I had a meeting.
I was sitting right next to him,
next to Mr. Kelly,
and here's what he said.
He said, "the President
of the United States,
"when he was campaigning,
made promises
that were not fully informed."
He said "I've educated
the President,
and the President
has evolved on the issue."
And when I asked General Kelly
"what's a wall?"
he said it could be
the inhospitable terrain,
it could be border patrol agent,
it could be drones.
-Oh, my God, this wall
keeps getting worse and worse.
It could be terrain,
it could be drones.
Soon, it's just going to be
a tunnel
painted on the side
of a mountain.
[ Laughter ]
So we have a President making
cartoonish demands
that everyone
knows are impractical.
There's absolutely
no guiding principles
or knowledge of policy, and he
changes his views on a whim
depending on who
he's talking to.
And a former campaign aide told
"The New York Times"
that Trump
doesn't even care to learn...
So it's simple.
It's not that he does not know
what he does not know,
it's that he does know
which means he doesn't know
what he does know
and he does think
that he doesn't need to know it.
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just to give you...
[ Applause ]
Just to give you an idea
of how incoherent
and scattershot Trump's views
are, he spent the weekend
bashing Democrats over DACA,
tweeting...
Even though he, himself,
has spent months insisting
that he wants to deal
with the DREAMers,
the young undocumented
immigrants
brought here as children,
with compassion.
-The DACA situation is a very,
very -- it's a very difficult
thing for me because, you know,
I love these kids.
I love kids. I have kids.
They shouldn't be very worried.
They are here illegally.
I do have a big heart.
We're going to take care
of everybody.
Well, I have a great heart for
the folks we're talking about.
A great love for them.
I feel having the Democrats
in with us is absolutely vital
because this should be
a bipartisan deal.
This should be a bill of love,
truly, should be a bill of love.
-Of course, a bill of love
is also what Trump pays
porn stars in hush money.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This weekend's shutdown was
very much the Trump presidency,
a microcosm, the President
with no guiding principles
and no knowledge of policy,
flailing wildly,
and relegated to making
cartoonish demands
from the sidelines while
everyone else scrambles
to figure out how
to make it work.
I don't know what Trump would
say about that,
but I do know how
his biggest critic feels.
-The whole world is looking
at us and laughing at us.
-He's right.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]